A few days ago, President Trump signed a
proclamation redeclaring today, Monday,
October the 13th, Columbus Day. A few
excerpts from his proclamation follow.
Quote, "Today, our nation honors the
legendary Christopher Columbus, the
original American hero, a giant of
Western civilization, and one of the
most gallant and visionary men to ever
walk the face of the earth. This
Columbus Day, we pledge to reclaim his
extraordinary legacy of faith, courage,
perseverance, and virtue from the
left-wing arsonists who have sought to
destroy his name and dishonor his
memory. Born in Genoa, Italy in 1451,
Columbus quickly emerged as a titan of
the age of exploration. On August 3rd,
1492, Columbus set out on a daring
expedition that most believed to be
impossible. Commissioned by Ferdinand
and Isabella of Spain, Columbus and his
crew boarded three small ships to set
sail on a perilous voyage across the
Atlantic. He was guided by a noble
mission to discover a new trade route to
Asia, bring glory to Spain, and spread
the gospel of Jesus Christ to distant
lands. Just over 2 months later, on
October 12th, 1492, Columbus made
landfall in the modern-day Bahamas. Upon
his arrival, he planted a majestic cross
in a mighty act of devotion, dedicating
the land to God and setting in motion
America's proud birthright of faith.
Outrageously, in recent years,
Christopher Columbus has been a prime
target of a vicious and merciless
campaign to erase our history, slander
our heroes, and attack our heritage.
Before our very eyes, left-wing radicals
toppled his statues, vandalized his
monuments, tarnish his character, and
sought to exile him from our public
spaces. Okay, let's focus on this
portion of Trump's proclamation. This
last portion, he's referring to the
fashionable revisionist claim championed
by the left that Christopher Columbus
was in fact the devil incarnate, that he
was a mass slaver and a genocidal
maniac. In reality, and judged by the
standards of his time, nothing Columbus
did was extraordinary. Even so, and not
least because Trump has come out in
favor of Columbus, the Columbus haters,
that is those who seek, in Trump's
words, to quote, "Ererase our history,
slander our heroes, and attack our
heritage," are coming out in full force.
The irony is that some of those hurling
stones live in very fragile glass
houses. Take the Yaken Institute, a
Texas-based Muslim Brotherhood linked
Islamic think tank, which according to
its own description, works to combat
Islamophobia.
A few days ago, it published a video
titled The Real Story of Christopher
Columbus, narrated by one Imam Tom,
apparently an American convert to Islam.
As might be expected, it engages in all
the sorts of defamation and propaganda
that Trump condemned in his
proclamation. Not only does the imam
present Christopher Columbus as a devil
incarnate, but he seems to imply that
any American who likes Columbus is
guilty by association. Take a look.
>> 32 towns and cities in America are named
after a mass murderer. How can someone
so widely celebrated be so guilty of
such heinous crimes? There's people that
are saying that, "Oh, he wasn't that bad
and this is tradition and this is our
history." We need to peel back the
layers on this one. The story of
Columbus is a story about taking pride
in the wrong things. Now, it's
incontrovertible that Columbus is guilty
of the crimes that he is charged with.
>> Now, why is Imam Tom who, as a Muslim,
lives in a very fragile glass house
hurling stones at anyone? Is he not
aware that virtually all of the heroes
of Islamic history are guilty of
similar, if not far worse, behavior than
Columbus? Let's take that one Muslim man
who dominated the 15th century. A
contemporary of Christopher Columbus'
Ottoman Sultan Muhammad or Mahmed II,
who lived between 1432 and 1481. During
his more than 30-year reign, he
conquered many Christian lands so that
he is today better known and honored by
Muslims as Muhammad the Conqueror. His
crowning achievement came in 1453 when
he Muhammad was 21 and Columbus was two.
I speak of the fall of Constantinople.
Muhammad's sole reason for conquering
that ancient Christian kingdom was that
it would not embrace Islam. Once he had
conquered it, he entered the ancient
Christian basilica, the Haga Sophia, the
Holy Wisdom, and ritually desecrated it,
including by destroying its altar,
breaking its crosses, and burning its
Bibles and icons before calling the
faithful to prayers and transforming it
into a mosque. Afterwards, he and his
Muslim conquerors engaged in countless
atrocities, defiling women, children,
and even men in the streets before
slaughtering them. A notorious
pedophile, Muhammad II himself enslaved
and sexually abused several Christian
boys, stabbing one to death because the
lad would not submit. Three days after
the Muslims had sated their barbaric
appetites, Muhammad had the wretched
citizens of Constantinople, I'm quoting
from an eyewitness source, Richerio
dragged before his men during evening
festivities and ordered many of them to
be hacked to pieces for the sake of
entertainment, he wrote. The rest of the
city's population, about 50,000, were
hauled off in chains to be sold as
slaves. And Constantinople was just one
of many such conquests. In 1480, when
Columbus was 29, Sultan Muhammad sent an
army to invade Italy. On conquering at
Toronto, the Muslims massacred more than
half of its 22,000 citizens and enslaved
5,000, mostly women and children. The
remaining 813 Christian prisoners,
mostly able-bodied men, were given a
choice. Embrace Islam or die. They all
chose Christianity and death and on
August 14th were ritually beheaded at
top a lonely hilltop in a Toronto. Their
archbishop was sawn in half to cries of
Allah Akbar. The skeletal remains of
some of these defiant Christians can
still be seen in the Cathedral of
Toronto. Watch this video for the full
story. One can go on and on about
Columbus's contemporary Sultan Muhammad
II. And I'm always coming across new
outrages committed by him. For example,
in my latest book, The Two Swords of
Christ, I include yet another little
known enormity. After he conquered
another Greek city, a reportedly very
beautiful slave girl by the name of
Irene was gifted to him. Muhammad became
enamored and spent so much of his time
with her that his men began to grumble
that he was losing his fighting spirit.
On hearing of this, he issued two
orders. First, that Irene be bathed and
essentially dolled up in a beautiful
gown, and second, that his leading men
and generals assemble in the palace
courtyard. He then had the beautiful
Irene escorted out to him. Holding her
by the hand and parading the
uncomfortable slave girl before his men,
he asked them if they had ever seen such
beauty. Then, as they all stood gawking
at young Gyne, Muhammad yanked her by
the hair, pulled out a sword with the
other hand, and sliced her head off,
boasting that that is how easy it is for
him to cut off anyone that gets in his
way. To reiterate, I'm telling you all
this to show you why Muslims of all
people should not be hurling stones at
Columbus, seeing how they live in glass
houses.
After all, this same Muhammad II has
statues in and is widely celebrated
throughout Turkey and is remembered and
honored every May 29th, which marks the
aforementioned horrific sack of
Constantinople, an otherwise glorious
event that the Turks celebrate every
year. By the way, unless it seemed that
Muhammad II was some sort of anomaly,
know that virtually every Muslim leader
throughout history behaved in a similar
fashion, massacring and enslaving people
simply because they would not embrace
Islam. And this goes all the way back to
Muhammad who in a canonical hadith
boasted, "I have been made victorious
through terror."
One of the more infamous acts of terror
was Muhammad's order, the prophet I'm
speaking of now, his order to ritually
behead about 700 male Jews right in
front of their enslaved women and
children, just like what happened to the
813 Christians at Toronto, Italy in
1480. I only focused on Sultan Muhammad
II because he was a contemporary of
Columbus to give you an idea of how
Muslims were behaving during Columbus'
era. If we really want to talk about
genocides, we can talk about how Muslims
butchered as many as 80 million Hindus
over the course of five centuries all in
the name of Islam according to historian
KS Lal. In short, if I imam Tom is
really concerned about and wants to
prevent people from looking up to the
bad guys, perhaps he should begin by
looking inward and helping his fellow
Muslims to see the light so they stop
heroizing and seeking to emulate any
number of Muslim leaders from their
prophet to the present, most of whom
engaged in horrific atrocities. Instead,
Imm shocked and upset because Americans
dare celebrate Christopher Columbus, a
man who, in Trump's words, quote, paved
the way for the ultimate triumph of
Western civilization. A civilization
which, whether they like it or not,
Muslims sure love relocating to and
living in. Now, let's get to the really
juicy part. Watch what Imam Tom has to
say here. Why did Columbus want to
please the king so bad? What was going
on here? There's something more
interesting at play. You've heard
probably that Columbus was sailing for a
different trade route. You might have
heard that Columbus was trying to find a
way around the Ottomans because the
Ottomans were controlling trade across
the land and he wanted to find a way
that got away from the Ottomans. But you
might not have realized what a big
crusader Columbus was. Columbus hated
Muslims. He was someone who wanted to
wage war against Muslims. In fact,
before he sailed to the new world, he
was fighting against Muslims in Spain,
like part of the so-called reconista or
the pushing out of Jews and Muslims from
Spain, that he was somebody who was
fighting against them there. He was a
zealot when it came to violence against
Muslim.
>> Good for you, Imm. Everything you said
here was true except of course for the
little bits you conveniently left out as
you once again engage in kit man that is
the Sharia compliant practice of lying
by omission. Anyone drowning in fake
history, that is the overwhelming
majority of people watching his video,
that is anyone not subscribed to my
channel, will take Imam Tom's words and
presentation as more proof that Columbus
was an evil man who simply hated Muslims
for no more a reason than that he was,
as anyone who celebrates him is a rabid
Islamophobe. Then there's reality. I've
already given you a small glimpse of the
atrocities Sultan Muhammad II and his
behemoth Ottoman army were committing
during Columbus' era. In reality,
however, it had been that way for nearly
800 years before Columbus was born. When
Muslims, having conquered nearly 3/4ers
of Christendom's original territory,
including all of the Middle East and
North Africa, first entered and
conquered portions of Europe, namely the
Iberian Peninsula or the Spain in the
year 7-Eleven AD. From that year on,
Europe and Islam were engaged in a death
struggle, especially following the rise
of the Turks, who began to invade and
conquer Eastern Europe in the early
1300s. As seen by the time Columbus was
born, not only had much of the Balkans
been conquered by the Ottoman Turks and
Russia by the Muslim Mongols, but
sources speak of many millions of
Europeans enslaved to the Turks, to the
Tatars, and to the Muslims of Barbary or
North Africa. As for the reconista,
which Imm dismisses as the so-called
reconista, this too was a very real
thing. It began soon after Muslims
invaded, terrorized, and conquered the
Iberian Peninsula in 7-Eleven and
continued for many centuries as
countless Spanish and Portuguese
Christians fought and died in their
attempt to liberate their homeland from
Islam. It was in this context that
Spain's monarchs Ferdinand and Isabella
themselves avowed crusaders who finished
the centuries long reconista of Spain by
liberating Granada from Islam in 1492
took Columbus into their service that
same year. They funded his ambitious
western voyage in an effort to launch,
in the words of historian Lewis
Bertrand, quote, a final and definite
crusade against Islam by way of the
Indies. And this culminated in the
incidental founding of the new world.
Many Europeans were convinced that if
only they could reach the peoples east
of Islam, who if not Christian, were at
least not as yet infected by the
Muhammadan plague, to quote Pope
Nicholas V, together they could crush
Islam between them. But because
traveling eastward, where the Ottomans
and other Muslims held sway was
suicidal, a new route had to be found.
Hence the true reason why Christopher
Columbus sailed west to continue the
crusade against Islam and even recover
Jerusalem. All this comes out in
Columbus's own letters. In one, he
refers to Ferdinand and Isabella as
quote enemies of the wretched sect of
Muhammad who are resolved to send me to
the regions of the Indies to see how the
people there can help. Don't believe me?
Here's a bit of actual truth from the
Imam. One of the authors, he said, "No
matter how many people Columbus shipped
to Spain for sale as slaves, no matter
how many others were rounded up for the
plantations, no matter how many tribes
were conquered, no matter how many new
lands were discovered, the wealth
acquired was never sufficient to fund a
Spanish armada to Jerusalem." That was
what Columbus wanted. Columbus wanted
Spain to recapture Jerusalem from the
Muslims. Again, the problem with Imam
Tom's presentation is not that it's
wrong, but that it consists of lies by
omission. The closest he'll get to offer
any meaningful context is that the
Ottomans were competitors who controlled
trade. No word or hint that they were
also invading, conquering, massacring,
and enslaving Christians. Instead, we
get these rather random assertions.
Columbus hated Muslims. He was someone
who wanted to wage war against Muslims.
In fact, before he sailed to the new
world, he was fighting against Muslims
in Spain. He was a zealot when it came
to violence against Muslims.
>> Again, these are all true statements.
The deception is that the Imam is
banking on the fact that most people
watching him are already so drunk on
fake history that learning that Columbus
was also a hate-filled Islamophobe will
only confirm the fashionable or woke
view that Columbus was indeed an evil
man. Incidentally, there's a little
irony here. Yes, Columbus and Ferdinand
and Isabella and every European then was
an Islamophobe, but not in the way that
word is used today. While the Greek word
phobos has always meant fear, its usage
today implies irrational fear. However,
considering that for nearly a thousand
years before Columbus, Islam had
repeatedly attacked Christendom to the
point of swallowing up most of its
original territory, including for
centuries Spain. that Islam's latest
iteration in the guise of the Ottoman
Turks was during Columbus' era
devastating the Balkans and
Mediterranean, slaughtering and
enslaving any European who dare travel
east through their domains. And that
even centuries after Columbus, Islam was
still terrorizing the West, marching
onto Vienna with 200,000 jihadists in
1683, and even provoking America into
its first war as a nation in 1800. The
very suggestion that western fears of
Islam were or are irrational is itself a
height of irrationalism. At any rate,
there it is some muchneeded truth about
Christopher Columbus and the many lies,
the fake history surrounding him.
[Music]